foreign
good afternoon everyone my name is Dr
Miller and the SCP we're going to be
looking at today is SCP 3060.
object class
ketter previously Euclid
special containment procedures
individual instances of scp-36d are to
be kept in high security lockers within
the storage wing of site-64 all testing
involving scp-36d requires the approval
of both the site Ethics Committee and
site command no more than four
individuals may be infected by scp-360
for testing purposes at any given time
individuals infected by scp-3060 are to
be kept in type 1 standard humanoid
containment chambers within the humanoid
anomaly containment wing of site-64.
cells have been equipped with alarm
systems to prevent instances from
entering REM sleep outside of designated
sleeping hours approximately 2200 to
0-600 local time during designated
sleeping hours all Personnel are to
evacuate from the radius of each
infected individual's anomalous effect
following termination of any individual
infected by scp-3060 containment
Personnel are to initiate a site-wide
lockdown and begin the hypnose protocol
to prevent the spread of infection
description
instances of scp-360 are small medical
devices that superficially resemble
continuous positive airway pressure or
CPAP machines the individual materials
that compose scp-360 instances are
non-anomalous and operate identically to
a typical CPAP machine of its size and
make the foundation currently has five
instances of scp-3060 in its custody
scp-3060 is anomalous effects become
apparent when worn by a sleeping human
when an individual wearing an instance
of scp-3060 enters their second REM
cycle a humanoid incorporeal entity
Hereafter referred to as
scp-3060a will appear within a 5 meter
radius of the individual and stand over
them until they wake up at this point
scp-3060a will disappear and the
individual wearing scp-360 will become
infected from that point on regardless
as to whether the individual wears
scp-3060 the
scp-3060a entity will appear when they
enter their second REM cycle each night
and remain until Awakening
while instances of scp-3060a appear as
featureless Silhouettes upon first
manifestation they quickly take on a
unique shape based on each infected
individual as such
scp-3060a entities have no standard
appearance while a full list of observed
scp-36da instances can be found in
document 3060b notable observed
instances include
a figure roughly the size of a human
infant composed entirely of fused teeth
a humanoid superficially resembling an
elderly woman dressed in dark clothes
lacking a mouth or eyes the instance his
arms are both severely injured with
compound fractures visible
a partially disintegrated humanoid
composed of Ash dressed in red lingerie
a naked humanoid covered in tire tracks
and showing signs of severe Crush
injuries
a humanoid whose torso consisted of a
large mouth
and a clown
while an scp-3060a entity stands within
the presence of an infected individual
any additional human subject that enters
a 50 meter radius of the infected will
enter a catatonic State at this point an
additional instance of scp-3060a will
appear within the proximity of the
infected individual the additional
scp-3060a entity will then approach the
catatonic subject phasing through solid
matter if the subject is in a separate
room upon arriving at the subject the
new
scp-36da instance will phase its hand
through the subject's skull and then
vanish causing the subject to
immediately fall asleep all subjects
touched by the scp-3060a entity in this
manner become new instances of scp-360
infected upon Awakening testing has
shown that Awakening the infected
whether through physical or auditory
stimuli following the appearance of an
scp-3060a entity will cause the latter
to immediately vanish and catatonic
subject to regain movement additionally
scp-360a entities will not approach
non-catatonic subjects outside of the
range of an infected individual's
anomalous properties non-human subjects
are immune to all of scp-3060's effects
all attempts to communicate with
scp-3060a instances have thus far been
met with failure
scp-360 infection has long-term effects
on the health of infected persons after
at least three days infected individuals
often begin to display fatigue mood
changes impaired performance and memory
problems even after obtaining a full
night's sleep infected individuals often
report frequent nightmares though no
Central themes or correlations have been
observed in the content of set dreams
within a month infected individuals will
often develop Visual and auditory
hallucinations as well as delusions that
their mind is no longer their own but
rather has been stolen by someone or
something soon after infected
individuals descend into full psychosis
as they become unable to distinguish the
content of their dreams from reality in
extreme cases after at least two months
of infection hair loss Kennedy sabita
partial or complete blindness somatic
complaints cataplexy and alien limb
syndrome have been observed attempts by
medical staff to alleviate these
conditions in the long term have thus
far been met with failure those symptoms
are delayed in individuals with previous
diagnosis of insomnia sleep deprivation
has likewise proven effective in
delaying the onset of the symptoms of
scp-3060 infection Research into a cure
is currently ongoing
if no human subjects enter the area of
an scp-3060 infected individual's effect
during REM sleep for seven consecutive
days or the infected individual dies an
instance of
scp-36da will appear The scp-360a Entity
will then proceed to search for the
nearest sleeping human upon locating
this individual
scp-3060a will stand over them until
they enter their next REM sleep cycle at
which point The scp-3060a Entity will
reach into their skull and vanish at
this point the sleeping individual will
become infected should these sleeping
individual awaken during the process or
scp-3060a be unable to locate a suitable
subject within three hours it will
vanish without spreading the scp-3060
infection
addendum 3060 a recovery
Foundation agents first became aware of
scp-360 on March 21 2015 when the entire
census of the Portland sleep Medical
Clinic became infected following a
volunteer sleep study using scp-360 to
prevent hypnagogic sleep paralysis all
infected individuals thereafter were
brought into Foundation custody and all
records related to the study seized by
Foundation operatives none of the
records seized indicated An Origin of
the scp-3060 instances and all staff
associated with the project died in
their sleep shortly upon being brought
into Foundation custody autopsies
revealed large quantities of
scp-3966a within the staff member's
cerebral spinal fluid an investigation
into Dr Cynthia Zhao the primary
investigator of the Portland sleep
medicine study associated with scp-3060
uncovered her to be a frequent user of
scp-2876 6. upon mobile task force
Omicron Rowe the Dream Team
investigation into potential one Arrow
involvement in the creation of scp-3060
contacts within the wanneroy collective
have denied responsibility for scp-3060
and have indicated that the
scp-2876 Ave had encountered no less
than four internal breaches of security
particularly in areas of user
information since its launch mobile task
force Omicron Rose investigation is
still ongoing
addendum 3060 B
video log transcript of test 36803
forward
the following events took place on April
2nd 2015 as part of the initial
containment experiments for scp-3060 an
scp-3060 infected individual was placed
in a standard humanoid containment cell
with instructions to go to sleep after
being fitted with sensors to monitor
brainwave patterns and Vital Signs
d-1260
d2860
d-2106 and d2306 were placed in nearby
cells within the same holding block as
the infected individual all cells were
equipped with CCTV cameras fitting into
the same monitor bank at approximately
2340 the infected individual entered her
second REM cycle
2345 21 d1260 is playing Solitaire at
the table in his cell d2860 is reading
on her caught d2106 is pacing within her
cell and d2306 has fallen asleep sitting
in his cell's chair
2345 58
scp-3060a1 appears standing over the
infected individual and resembles a
headless humanoid with arms and legs
replaced by spinal columns shortly after
an additional four instances of
scp-360a appear each additional instance
resembles a featureless humanoid
silhouette the instances remain standing
over the infected for the next five
minutes all d-class Personnel appear to
have become catatonic those d-class
awake have expressions of distress upon
their face
scp-3060a2 turns and leaves the infected
cell phasing through the door and
entering the hallway where it then
phases into d2306's cell
d-360a2 stands over d2306 for several
seconds then bends over and places its
face near d2306's ear before reaching
into his skull
23 55 30. the 3060 A3 faces through the
floor and vanishes for several moments
before phasing up through the floor of
d2860 cell through her cot then through
her
scp-3060a3 remains motionless for
several moments as it looks down at
d2860 who appears to be struggling
against her catatonic State
scp-3060a3 then slowly reaches out and
closes d2860s eyes with its hand then
reaches into her skull
2355 45
scp-36da2 removes its hand from d2306's
Skull and takes the shape of a male
human with mathematical symbols in place
of facial features
scp-30682 vanishes
2356 15.
scp-3060a4 climbs up the cell wall and
phases through the ceiling and vanishes
for several moments before phasing into
d2106's cell through the ventilation
grade the instance drops down and walks
around d2106 as she struggles against
her catatonic State
d-2106 Falls over
scp-3060a4 wraps its arms around d2106
and begins to caress her head after
several moments of this
scp-360-a4 reaches into d2106's skull
2357 46
scp-360-a3 removes its hand from d2860
Skull and takes the shape of a humanoid
composed of a tightly wound threat a
variety of spiders are visible crawling
in and out of openings along
scp-3060a3's body
scp-3060a3 vanishes
2356 42
scp-3060a5 leaves the infected cell
phasing through the walls from cell to
cell before finally arriving at d1260 so
scp-3060a5 stands across the table from
d1260 starring Adam for several moments
while caressing his hand t-1260
struggles against his catatonic State
scp-3060-a5 reaches into d1260 skull
zero zero 47
scp-3060a4 removes its hands from
d2006's Skull and takes the shape of a
featureless white humanoid dressed in a
foundation lab coat
d36da4 vanishes
0 2 30.
scp-36da5 removes its hand from d1260
Skull and takes the shape of a
featureless black humanoid dressed in an
amalgamation of paraphernalia from
various authoritarian regimes the 36da5
vanishes
zero five thirty eight
scp-3060a1 remains standing over the
infected until she awakens at
approximately zero four fifty zero zero
addendum 3060 C interview log 3060 6.
the following interview was conducted as
part of routine mental health monitoring
for scp-360 infected individuals on o303
2016.
interviewed researcher Joanna Corbin
interviewer researcher Roland Farrow
forward
the interview took place approximately
one and a half months following
researcher Corbin's infection by
scp-3060 during the 15-1 2016
containment breach of an instance of
scp-360-a researcher Corbin had begun to
report Visual and auditory
hallucinations one week earlier due to
her knowledge on scp-360's effect and
prior diagnosis of insomnia researcher
Corbin has shown remarkable resistance
to scp-360's hallucinogenic effect
playing log now
evening Joanna evening Roland sorry if
I'm not exactly 100 today to be frank
I'm exhausted it's hard to concentrate
when the walls are bleeding don't sit
there research of pharaoh pauses as he
begins to sit in his chair he then
stands and straightens his life coat may
I ask why
ask me Roland I
am much more composed if I don't have to
watch you sit in that chair the
hallucinations have progressed to that
severity already they have it's like my
eyes are constantly getting these little
pop-ups of nonsense and then there's
this [__] voice that keeps commenting
on things yeah I'm talking about you
shut up
the auditory hallucinations are constant
at this point then just the one
I personally like to think it's the
voice of the 3060a if it's creeping on
me but I have no way to prove that and
it's not like it's going to tell the
truth researcher Corbin rubs her eyes
for several moments and sighs heavily I
[Applause]
feeling more exhausted than what I went
to bed and when I wake up it's like and
taking the nightmares with me like the
barrier between my conscious and
subconscious has become a sieve or
something
these auditory hallucinations what do
they researcher Corbin covers her mouth
with her hand and stifles a mixture of
tears and laughter she then points at
researcher Pharaoh your face has just
melted off rolling we should probably
hurry this up
I don't know how much more I can take
right right
these auditory hallucinations what kind
of things do they say comments on
thoughts I have on things I see
sometimes asks me about myself
I have to say when the other infected
said they felt like their mind wasn't
their own I didn't really know what they
were saying but
but I sure as hell do now do you believe
that the voice is trying to control you
command you influence you in any way
[__] if I know Roland if it is it's
doing a pretty shitty job at it honestly
I'd say it's just here for the headspace
and to enjoy the ride but again what the
hell do I know research at Colby then
closes her eyes and places
can we be done please
I'm afraid we have just a few more
things to get through before we're done
bear with me all right researcher
Pharaoh quickly writes down several
sentences on a piece of notebook paper
intelligence I'm writing down a few
questions that I'm going to want you to
ask it researcher Pharaoh slides the
piece of paper to researcher Corbin
Corbin eyes the document for several
moments then turns her head towards the
edge of the table corbyn then sighs in
frustration before rubbing her temples
marched like
we're going to need some confirmation
before I can move forward in that
direction researcher Pharaoh takes the
piece of paper back and begins to read
aloud
you a separate entity from Joanna corbyn
number three do you exist within her
mindscape or are you based in some other
researcher Corbin rapidly backs away
from researcher Pharaoh in fear flipping
over the table on the way
here what
there research at Colbin removes her
jacket and tackles pharaoh to the ground
and attempts to Snuff out a fire on
Pharaoh's person security Personnel
intervene and pull Corbin off Pharaoh
keeping her restrained as she struggles
to free herself for a total of two
minutes eventually Corbin yields Pharaoh
then orders the security Personnel to
release her Corbin proceeds to lower
herself onto the floor and crawl away
she then sits in the far corner of the
room in tears
I couldn't watch you die like that I
can't answer these questions I [__]
can't do this researcher Pharaoh
approaches research at Corbin in an
attempt to comfort her Corbin
immediately pulls herself into the fetal
position
get away from me researcher Pharaoh
pauses for several moments then nods in
agreement
clustered moment
researcher Pharaoh leaves researcher
Corbin attempts to read the list again
after what appeared to be multiple
attempts she screams out in frustration
crumbles the paper and throws it against
the nearby War researcher Corbin then
places her head in her hands
and log
addendum 3060 D update 2210 2016.
on October 22nd 2016 a curvier
pharmaceutical advertisement for scp-360
appeared in over 100 Publications in the
United States Canada and Europe by the
time Mass censorship protocols could be
enacted and the source of the ad was
traced to a curvier logistics Warehouse
in Seattle Washington approximately 3
000 instances of scp-360 had been
shipped with mobile task force Alpha 4
Pony Express operatives able to stop
2700 in transit an additional 270
instances of scp-36d were later captured
at their destinations currently 30
instances of scp-3060 remain uncontained
Warehouse staff were oblivious to the
effect of the devices when interviewed
having all been hired within the last
two weeks over half of these individuals
were users of scp-2876 prior to their
higher date all Warehouse staff brought
into Foundation custody died in their
sleep shortly afterward as before large
quantities of
scp-3966a were found within the
warehouse staff's CSF during autopsy an
investigation into both curvier
pharmaceutical and curvier Logistics is
ongoing
as of 25 10 2016 an unknown number of
scp-360 infected individuals are
currently believed to be uncontained
with outbreaks occasionally occurring in
several major metropolitan areas
attempts to contain scp-360 infected
individuals are ongoing due to scp-3060
infection remaining largely undetectable
within the general public until end
stage symptoms manifest several mobile
task forces are on standby to
investigate reports of multiple
psychotic breaks and acts of violence
occurring within a short time frame
within the same geographic area
scp-3060's object class has subsequently
been updated to ketter pandemic levels
of scp-360 infection are currently being
considered a potential AK Class end of
the world scenario
okay I think that about does it for
today
thank you for listening if indeed you
still are
and you are all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to zargaron
except
oh crap guy
Trey Adams
the Morrigan
James Saba
Irish wristwatch
Lost Boy
your local Foundation agent
sagnar
zazapan
worthy fire
Dr Wolf 13.
cubster
Dean dingus
braided Peach
Rowan O'Brien
cake knock
gremnir
extra moments one two three
and James Wright
if you would like a special thank you at
the end of each of my videos and some
other cool stuff as well visit
patreon.com forward slash the volgan
thank you